electric bikes are powering their way
across Europe increasingly popular the
bikes are also at the center of an
international trade dispute at the heart
of the matter is dumping a practice that
involves foreign companies selling their
state subsidized products at below
market prices in this case Chinese made
electric bikes are being sold cheaply in
Europe which the EU believes threatens
businesses and jobs we have more and
more conflicts over trade worldwide
right now and the EU framework for trade
advanced instruments and anti dumping is
old it's not been reformed since the 90s
but today's world is of course very
different to the 90s mesh is already in
place include applying tariffs to
products that the EU determines are
undermining homegrown businesses but
higher import taxes aren't the only
answer if we have rules we have to have
ways to force people to play by the
rules and therefore I think that trade
defense instruments actually play an
important role in addition to tariff
increases some changes on the table
includes shorter anti-dumping
investigations and the creation of a
helpdesk to process complaints lodged by
small businesses the Parliament also
aims to involve trade unions as part of
its aim to modernize the process
[Music]
you